i'm gonna do a 180 now and i'm gonna i'm
i'm going to
to to be a rain of sunshine on your
parents bring it
the sky is clearing up the acid rain is
going away people are
are now looking up at the sunlight i
don't trust although their acid acid
rain
riddled skin is being hurt by the
sunlight they're still smiling to see it
i'm going back underground now
you're gonna you're gonna love this one
ladies and gentlemen we got this amazing
story check this out
yeah project veritas has an update in
their lawsuit with the new york times
and the new york times is tripping over
themselves
and taking a dump on their own
credibility in a desperate attempt to
stop james o'keefe
is glorious so james put out an update
video
the defense the new york times is going
with is that they have no idea what's
going on
they didn't actually investigate james
o'keefe for his story they didn't talk
to any
any people involved or ask anyone for
comment it was a bunch of opinions
and they they're completely ignorant of
anything that happened in this case this
is their without malice part of the
argument
but this means that james o'keefe has
just taken an
axe to the base of the fake news
narrative tree
in his in in the veritas video they
point out how
after the new york times says this usa
today cites the new york times
saying project veritas is part of
coordinated disinformation
then you get wikipedia and you get
twitter facebook
all running the same story and banning
this based on the on the fact that the
new york times said it was true
and now the new york times has admitted
in no uncertain terms
in a court of law one it was just our
opinion two we didn't actually follow up
on any of this story and three
we honestly have no idea what's going on
anyway that's malicious
yeah well malicious is a reference to
knowing it's false right so what they're
saying is we're
totally clueless about this story so it
can't be malice
maybe not malice um what would you call
it not legal matter when you just like
fire a gun everywhere without looking
and then it hits somebody religion yeah
negligence convincing a depraved mind
negligence was the word i was looking
for negligence is that illegal can you
hit someone on negligence
what i love is that all these news
organizations take the same tact
it's like oh we're not actually
reporting facts we don't actually
investigate stuff we're just talking
we're just speculating it's like
willfulness it's one thing when tucker
carlson
is defending himself in a suit and says
it's an opinion show that no one should
take seriously or whatever
it's another thing when the new york
times runs a fact-based news story in
their
main news section and has to admit to
the court these are not opinion writers
these are news reporters
who published in the news section
unverified
opinions that they did not investigate
anyway so they're either malicious or
incompetent
dumb or diabolical all the things that
we've been talking about for
years now coming to the forefront but
guess who's gonna care
guess how much traction that story is
gonna get guess how much of an impact
that's gonna make in american people's
minds
that the new york times admits that they
don't fact check they don't research
they don't investigate the stories that
they put out as fact
how much influence is that going to have
none
that much guys that much are you got
your neck
are you making a no it's a neck it's a
neck thing it's a neck thing you see the
story of the jeopardy contestant
who did the three-pointer hand sign
because he won three times and they
started screaming he was a white
supremacist
this poor you know what's funny is that
this guy could win jeopardy and still
not
understand the context of the okay
gesture definitely it's like dude
you you you read trivia all day
certainly you read the news story about
why you don't make that because that's
certainly
trivial so project veritas still is
this is good because it is part of the
battle and
veritas is suing twitter as well and cnn
and they're probably going to win
yes and it's going to empower veritas
more
and it at least you know someone is
fighting back and having a good go at it
however regular people watching cnn
won't hear it and the people who already
like veritas will and be like
good but it's a tool for all of you
if you're somebody who is sick and tired
yes you ian know him
no jack jack if you are somebody who has
friends and family
and i know it's difficult because a lot
of people are like my parents my friends
they won't watch the stuff they won't
read the news anyway they don't want to
hear it
it's one more thing we can be like oh
hey look at that the new york times
admits they don't actually fact check
their stories
at the very least you can do this dude
they won't even believe it though you
could read it to them
new york times in the new york times
them saying they don't they won't even
believe it but
no no no it's all about how you present
it if you go to a family member let's
say you got a joe biden supporting
family member
and you go to them and go biden is awful
you know i'll tell you why i can't
believe you vote for him and you argue
with him like man get out of here get i
don't
gotta get out of here but if you walk up
to him you go do you see that crazy
thing that that lawsuit or something
the new york times apparently admitted
they don't even fact check their stories
weird huh and that's that's all i say
that's neutral that's good
it's just i don't know and then they're
like what does that mean they're like i
don't know i guess i'll subscribe to usa
today or something because
yeah and you don't you don't make it a
big thing you don't tie it to things you
just tell them outright
so you're sitting there you're like do
you hear about that story uh the other
day like i guess
like the new york times got sued and
then they came out and just admitted
they their their news stories have have
unverified opinion
they're not fact checking man that's
crazy i guess you know i'll probably
just you know take a different paper i
guess
that's crazy but you know at the
washington post they used to do fact
checking of the president they stopped
doing that did you hear that
oh yeah some do joe biden yeah something
to joe joe by his present now we don't
need to fact-check him because he's not
actually really saying those things
they just announced that today they just
announced that today because they don't
think it's actually joe biden
no it's whoever's writing his talking
points so therefore they don't need to
fact check the president okay
guys hey george bush went into iraq but
you know what it was based on the
information of other people that they
gave him but that doesn't matter
doesn't matter no one needs to be held
responsible for anything anymore
because uncle joe papa joe he president
now and everything's okay
yeah i love these tweets from the the
establishment lefties who are like
i woke up on sunday and everything was
great because trump didn't tweet and
it's like
you open the news and it's like joe
biden bombs syria or whatever right did
he bomb siri already no he didn't right
no no no i believe i believe that they
did and i believe
they did yep and there was also uh a a
shot fired at an iranian ship i believe
oh yeah i remember that because i
tweeted that one out i said orange man
orange man made me do it sorry i'm sorry
biden
biden launched an airstrike against
syria one month into his presidency
right
exactly so it's like you know these
people are all cheering and have you
seen the commercial where the woman
she's working at a shop and the the the
flowers in the shop are talking to her
and she's singing and it's like disney
and the puddle goes i'm gonna put lisa
on crutches and then everything turns
back to normal and she goes what
and then the guy's like you know you got
to get crutches man and it's
you know an insurance commercial or
something it's a good commercial but i
see that it reminds me of like these
these biden people who are now posting
biden sucks
you know biden voters posting their l's
this is a twitter account for this
and it's the people who are like during
the election going like yeah and they're
all like singing good morning star shine
or whatever and holding hands under the
rainbow
and then a month then they're like
everything is dark and gloomy and
and awful and there's a there's a dark
filter on the lens that makes you just
feel miserable
you know what's interesting i thought
that being right would make me feel good
no it really really does feel worse it
makes me
feel worse it's being part of the crowd
that makes you feel good
yes being right when everything's going
so wrong
every step of the way it's like ah if
you have a lot of people with you
agreeing with you and acknowledging that
you're right it helps i have
a hundred and eight thousand now two
people on twitter
agreeing with me largely and it still
doesn't help it makes me feel terrible
being right one of the greatest people
in history
died in poverty they were hated
throughout their lives they were
persecuted they were
like socrates was made to drink poison
he
they weren't accepted but that doesn't
make them wrong
so maybe you're one of those people well
i'm definitely not in poverty so i'm
winning
socrates got you buddy you're doing
better than this so great
i don't know man it's kind of it's kind
of worrying to me that we've built a
culture
a society of people who are desperate to
just be a part of the crowd i would
think we'd be passing that no
no no no that's not as we didn't build a
society that does that that's human
nature bro that's human nature
everywhere all across time all across
everything
why because we thrive in small groups
yeah but look at sparta dude those
people were
nuts yeah but they had the opposite we
don't want to go that direction either
but i'm saying like
that you can build a society that's like
i mean they would like
what would they do wouldn't they like
test babies
yeah they would get they would kill any
sick babies no but wouldn't they like
hold them under water or something i
don't know
some something ridiculous where it was
like if the baby survived it was strong
enough
warrior keep warrior kids with fights
in the military from age uh either six
or eight to
thirty every every spartan was in the
military i'm not i'm not all about that
they were training but we have the
opposite where it's like you know
you've seen idiocracy right yes those
those those that reproduce the most wins
so it's like you combine idiocracy with
wall-e
where you have all the people just
morbidly obese in hover chairs
and that's what we've been for a long
time we've been a nation of
just life's too good too easy no
conflict no challenge no struggle
and it is it's our own well i'd say it's
our own fault but i wasn't alive
and i think you know we here on the show
are are you know trying desperately to
get people to care about the future of
this planet
and and things like that but there are
people of previous generations i guess
it's you know
good men i'm sorry good times make weak
men
weak men make hard times maybe the hard
times are going to make some strong men
in the next generation
things will turn around that american
dream where they're like i'm just going
to get my own little plot of land and
everyone else can
screw off and i'll protect my family and
everyone else goodbye that's that's not
good because
what that's done is created like this
subsection of plutocrats that are like
i'm going to protect myself and let the
rest of society no no
no no no no the number one factor to
resist
tyranny is the power to feed and protect
yourself
if you have land and you can feed
yourself that is the
best protector against tyranny there
ever was
that is why rome it was a big deal to
have land and take care of yourself
and as soon as they stop as soon as like
land owning stopped being as dispersed
as it was
warriors and soldiers couldn't own land
anymore or stop becoming a requirement
uh in order to be a uh in the army
land holding got consolidated by
wealthiest aristocrats
and the people didn't have land to take
care of themselves that's the problem
in america if we everybody was
homesteading if everybody could have
their own food
their own energy their own warmth their
own land their own security
well that is a mighty fine resistance to
tyranny you're saying it's like
when the wealthy took away the ability
of the regular people to have
land and survive they became dependent
upon that system yes
so where are you leading me tim i don't
know you know i'm thinking about this
and i'm wondering if
what if what if the workers of the world
united united
i see the world i can't i do
that was too gentle you were just you
were just drawing me
in there you're like what are you doing
no how about this farmers of the world
unite
that's better i'll allow no no hold on
hold on
see i i see they they take that
statement workers of the world unite
and it's become a bad thing because of
the darkness that's that that's behind
it
exploitation but regular working
people agreeing to defend each other
from
exploitation and the corrupt political
elites is not a bad thing
no the bad thing is when the corrupt
political elite says hey i'm we're going
to get all the workers to unite now just
do as i'm do do as you're told
or else exactly that's the problem to
clarify the american dream or whatever
of having your own land and protecting
having
and how that's a problem is that i think
that some people just stop
there and that's it and then they don't
care about other people
and and so they they're okay if other
people are suffering like well he
arrested that guy
it's not my problem and the isolationist
mentality that kept us out of world war
ii for instance
so there's more to it yeah you want your
own property and your own
your own food but you have to think
about and care for
others i know it's not like you don't
want to politicize it and make people do
it but we need to do that
what's funny is about when people do
have their own land and their own
sustenance and their own heat and their
own protection
the need to actually engage with and
care about other people and your
interaction with other
it just it decreases right it's that can
it's that connectivity
especially over long range distances to
bring us all together into this
proximity that we're not accustomed to
this is actually part of the problem and
that's why they want everybody to have
guns
so in a good in the good way right right
right you if you have your property you
don't really
you know have you guys seen them you've
seen the movie the patriot with mel
gibson
yes what an amazing movie yeah but the
british hate it apparently because it
makes them look like villains but
oh the british it was pure propaganda
but but but there's that there's that
scene where
mel gibson's like we're going into town
and they're like oh we're going into
town because you don't
go into town like you live in a farm you
work you do nothing but work going to
town was like a rare thing
before the telephone but so right right
it's like a mail carrier has delivered a
mail and you're everyone gathers around
what is it what's the message oh man
because oh
i i've been looking at chickens for six
months give me something to read
but so what happens is back then
everybody needs to be ready and able to
defend themselves
because how if someone starts invading
your your land
how will you get word out to the local
militia to the community
you've got to be ready and able to
defend yourself then when conflict
starts
word will spread eventually and then
people can start mobilizing but in the
meantime
you need to be able to have to have you
you need to keep and bear arms
i'm gonna agree with ian a little bit on
this one because this is actually
something i've really been thinking
about and i'll explain myself
this is like the underlying idea okay so
this is a problem that i've actually
watched
you can make fun of me out here i don't
know i beg you for the idiot but i love
you and we know this
it's fine okay let me let me finish okay
so this is the underlying issue i think
in like the libertarian party and to
some extent in the conservative movement
is that
this idea of the individual is so much
higher than every other ideal
and i understand how important that is
and i fully respect and
appreciate that that's crucial but ian
is right that we need to have that
community and tim just talked about that
he's like you need to be able to defend
yourself you need to be able to gang up
with other people when it's time to rise
to the occasion and fight the bad guys
that's right a well-regulated militia
exactly like that's a group
you know yeah and by regulated i think
we mean trained and equipped
right functioning thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you